[Musique]
jusqu'au drame capitale du nord de
l'albanie capitale aussi du kanun une
loi moyenâgeuse venus des montagnes
c'est ici que choisit de s'installer sur
christina cette religieuse originaire
d'allemagne se bat depuis des années
contre les canaux
depuis trois mois elle s'occupe d'alfred
il a 13 ans alfred ne va pas à l'école
depuis huit ans il vit cloîtrée alfred
est menacée de mort
[Applaudissements]
alfred est le seul garçon de la famille
mais pentue ans alfred on efface la
ligne et ça fait de lui la victime
idéale car il n'y a plus d'autres
descendants mâles
une prime nba n'a jamais pesté
le père d'alfred convoyeur de fonds est
mort assassiné dans une embuscade pour
le venger un membre de sa famille a tué
trois personnes condamnées à 15 ans de
prison ferme le maximum prévu par la loi
il purge sa peine mais pour les familles
des trois victimes
seule compte la vengeance ils veulent
tuer alfred
bonjour bonjour quand vas-tu bien ça va
tu vis ici maintenant vous êtes un peu
serré non tu vas rester longtemps
on est là pour très peu de temps on va
devoir à nouveau partir
alors viens alfred
qu'est ce que tu m'as manqué comment
vas-tu bien
on constate qu est-ce que cette ferait
plaisir de venir avec nous tu veux aller
3 et sinon il n'y a pas de jardin pour
toi chez nous tu vas jouer oui
[Musique]
ce match a été bon moi je parle de vin
pour prévenir la boj
[Applaudissements]
sa mère par la première elle veut
s'assurer que la voie est libre alfred
ne sort qu'en compagnie de soeur
cristina dehors elle est sa seule
protection
mais alfred a toujours peur dans la
voiture ils refusent de s'asseoir près
de la fenêtre
alpha mais je prends un gauche là c'est
ça
oui c'est ça après tu tourne à droite
personne ne doit connaître la nouvelle
adresse d'alfred
très bien c'est par là
soeur cristina n'est pas rassurée elle
fait très attention à ne pas être suivi
cette sortie est si important pour le
jeune garçon qu'il veut aller se changer
mais comme ils déménagent très souvent
ces vêtements sont chez sa grand mère
dès son arrivée il court à l'arrière de
la maison cachée par les vignes
de l'autre côté vivent deux des trois
familles qui cherchent à se venger
[Musique]
mettez sa grand mère comme toutes les
femmes du clan ce n'est pas menacé dans
le canot seuls les hommes sont en péril
bonjour je ne te dérange pas j'espère
n'ont rentré
alfred commence à se détendre une fois
enfilé son tee shirt préféré tpr est
très bien tu as fait vite un thé tout
beau il affiche son premier sourire de
la journée
[Musique]
le kanun prévoit une possibilité de
pardon dans les vendettas soeur cristina
veut savoir où en sont les négociations
avec les familles qui veulent créer
alfred mais les nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes alors vous en est où
j'ai parlé avec eux mais ça ne sert à
rien vraiment classe comme sûre mais ils
sont fous ces gens là ils disent qu'on
ne peut rien faire il y a trois
personnes de tuer vos sacs alfred doit
trop de sang qu'elles ne veulent rien
savoir
c'est très important et une nuits de
demander pardon pour alfred il ne faut
pas être fier mais je le ferai
j'ai demandé à ta grand mère qu'elle
continue dans la voie de la
réconciliation
qu'elle allait demander pardon tu es
d'accord d'accord oui
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
le couvent est un refuge pour toutes les
victimes de la vendetta
surtout pour les enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
soeur cristina à réaliser le voeu le
plus cher d'alfred lui trouver un ami et
ses clés vis un petit garçon de 11 ans
venue spécialement le voir son seul
copain
avec lui il va le temps d'une après-midi
redevenir un enfant presque comme les
autres
faut pas faire de bruit le petit d'or
[Musique]
victor également victime de la vendetta
est là aussi avec eux c'est l'aîné de la
vente il sorte de grand frère
[Musique]
ici avec les soeurs je me sens plus en
sécurité
[Musique]
avec la menace d'être tués à tout moment
on ne peut pas vivre une vie normale
[Musique]
les soeurs ne s'occupe pas seulement des
enfants elle donne du travail à ces
femmes
maris pères frères office se cachent
dans les montagnes ils ne peuvent
subvenir aux besoins de la famille
la pauvreté va de pair avec la violence
c'est le terreau du canal
je pense même que la vengeance est
alimentée par la pauvreté
ça commence par le fait que les gens
s'endettent pour construire leur maison
ou simplement parce qu'ils tombent
malades puis arrive le moment où ils
sont dans l'impossibilité de rembourser
le créancier réclame son argent ils
menacent deux fois et après c'est le
meurtre nous avons ici déjà les premiers
cas de dettes de sans doute à cause de
l'argent
alfred le foot il ne le voit qu'elle a
télé
ici cour de récréation avec ces quelques
balles échangées mais pas pour longtemps
les soeurs ont peur de le laisser jouer
dans la peau
c'est l'heure de rentrer le sourire
d'alfred s'éclipse
arrivé chez lui pas le temps d'échanger
un au revoir il se remet à l'abri des
murs
e
[Musique]
au fil de notre voyage dans le pays de
ses traditions meurtrière nous mesurons
l'ampleur de la vendetta un tiers de la
population du pays seraient touchés par
la loi du sang
[Musique]
un pays où presque chaque famille
possède une arme et où une dette de 100
concerne tous les mâles d'un même clan
sur cette génération
[Musique]
mais que se passe-t-il quand il n'ya
plus d'hommes pour accomplir une
vengeance le clown a tout prévu c'est ce
que l'on appelle ici le serment des
vierges des femmes qui prennent la place
des hommes pour laver le sang du clan
des femmes qui renoncent aussi à se
marier pour exercer leur vengeance ou
bien encore des veuves
c'est le cas de beaucoup rire il y a
huit ans son mari a été assassiné devant
elle elle ignore les raisons de ce crime
bien beau je suis l'homme
rebours alors depuis qu'il est mort je
porte le pantalon
je suis l'homme la mer et le chef du
clan
beaucoup ri à nous montre la photo de
son mari pour elle le sent se lavent par
le sang
ait je le tuerais c'est la loi du doigt
sur la gâchette
je veux tu es celui qui a tiré les
autres hommes de se mouiller ne
m'intéresse pas ouais vous on est jeté
et où est l'état où est la loi meurtre
pour meurtre si l'état avait fait
quelque chose s'il était condamné à vie
je n'aurai pas à me venger
mon mari ne devait rien à personne son
meurtrier a fui il se promène libre
neurones et moi je suis la seule avec
mes filles i l'état n'a pas fait son
travail moi je le ferai
[Musique]
pour échapper à la vendetta beaucoup
d'albanais du nord du pays puis vers la
capitale nous partons vers tirana à une
heure et demie de route de shkodra
dans cette ville d'un million
d'habitants des centaines de familles
trouvent refuge dans l'anonymat
là leur seul espoir ce sont les
réconciliateurs il tente d'obtenir le
pardon de ce qui les menace
jean marcoux est un ancien agent des
services de renseignement il travaille
depuis des années avec ces familles en
mur et
on se rend chez une famille qui vit
cloîtrée
on va essayer de les aider dans leurs
démarches de réconciliation
c'est un endroit caché ou leur sécurité
est a priori assurée mais cela n'empêche
même ici la famille est en danger
on doit prendre des précautions il dit
est à mostar les montages et un second
dans votre famille
non mais qui soyez discret
[Musique]
c'est moi jim
avec moi je ne suis pas seul mais
t'inquiète pas
à notre arrivée la famille s'inquiète
nos images ne doivent pas révélé
l'endroit où vit pietri menacé de mort
comment va pietri et de linge
t'inquiète pas c'est la télévision
française c'est pour un documentaire
kloten
s'est diffusée en france paquet pas
c'est pas la télévision al banna l'air
qui est triste c'est lui il a 24 ans et
cette maison est devenue sa prison
la terrasse est devenue une cour
intérieure murs et de toutes parts pour
mieux le protéger
il vit ici entouré des femmes
endeuillées et des enfants de sa famille
sous le regard des hommes du clan tous
assassinés il ya 11 ans dans un bureau
de vote
fin mai la famille a tout fait rire
quand bolt profite elle a même envoyé
des hommes pour demander le pardon à la
famille des victimes et familles
[Musique]
et nous au comité après on envoyait une
délégation de 50 hommes pour appuyer
cette demande de pardon mais beaucoup de
sang a été versé quatre personnes ont
été tuées et les familles pour l'instant
refuse tout dialogue
quand est-ce qu'ils y sont allés en 2003
non non en 2004 et en 1998 on y est allé
aussi à huy en 1998 aussi
en
98 c'était la première fois mais en 2004
c'était mieux organisés
sans réconciliation
l'avis de pietri et toujours menacée il
est le dernier homme de la famille il
passe ses journées depuis des années
dans les deux pièces de cette maison
prêtée par des amis
des ravages du temps je dors là et ma
mère d'or du côté de la fenêtre
jusqu'à 11 heures parfois même jusqu'à
midi et
je ne sors pas de la chambre après je
vais dans l'autre pièce c'est ça ma
journée
je me sens inutile bon à rien
je ne peux pas aider ma famille je
souffre et c'est pas important ce qui
fait mal c'est que je vois les miens
souffrir aussi et que je ne peux rien
faire
je me lève le matin et je pense chaque
jour à sortir et advienne que pourra
c'est normal
j'espère toujours que ce sera une
journée de liberté quand tu reste
enfermé c'est comme si tu es mort
oui
j'ai peur très peur qu'un jour je ne
pourrais pas le retenir car il est
désespéré ici enfermé je le supplie tous
les jours de ne pas sortir je lui dis
que je vais m'occuper de lui et que je
vais tout faire pour qu'il quitte le
pays je vais frapper à toutes les portes
pour qu'ils puissent partir mais je n'ai
pas les moyens
depuis son adolescence qui est review
huit clos avec sa mère pas de copain pas
de petite amie seule évasion les visites
des voisins et la télévision
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand la réconciliation est impossible
jean marcou temps d'envoyer les familles
menacées à l'étranger
c'est du bureau du comité de
réconciliation qu'il dirige les
opérations
[Musique]
un bassin minier c'est l'ambassade ils
veulent leur rapport sur cette famille
des peuples et moins ils veulent des
renseignements alors tu vas prendre tout
ça avec ton collègue tu vas là-bas et tu
va nous aider à éclaircir ce cas
c'est l'ambassade allemande
ils veulent vérifier si la
réconciliation a eu lieu ou si la
vengeance continue
ces cinq dernières années selon di marco
500 familles ont été évacuées vers
l'étranger l'exil une solution de plus
en plus fréquentes avec l'augmentation
des vendettas
actuellement le cas nous on est très
fort
il est au dessus des lois pour les
albanais du monde entier
je dirais même que le kanun est bien au
dessus de l'état cette bible de la bible
et du coran c'est le seul moyen de
trouver justice car l'état est faible
bien trop faible
mais tout le monde n'a pas les moyens de
fuir
alors ceux qui restent lors le kanun les
frappes se barricadent ses murs parfois
construit en une nuit hérissée de
tessons de bouteille rehaussé de
barbelés sont censés les protéger
ce quartier appelé le quartier des
emmurés est né il ya quinze ans après
l'effondrement du régime communiste
le kanun interdit jusque là a pris le
relais
une solidarité invisible lit toutes ces
familles tout visage inconnu est
immédiatement repéré
dans le nord du pays plus de 5000
personnes et au moins 1500 enfants
seraient touchés par la vendetta
comment vivre derrière ces murs comment
supporter l'enfermement des années
durant soeur cristina tente de briser l
isolement elle est à la fois postière
assistantes sociales infirmières
mais parfois cela ne suffit pas
après sept ans d'enfermement un
adolescent dont elle s'occupait est
sorti de chez lui dix minutes plus tard
il était abattu de deux balles une des
200 peser sur la famille à cause d'un
oncle à la gâchette facile
il avait 17 ans et s'appelait zf avec
les enfants du couvent soeur cristina à
ériger cette stèle
voilà là je ne peux pas l'avoir comme ça
c'est vraiment trop sale
mais sur christina ne veut pas seulement
honorer la mémoire de zf et tente de
faire passer un message auprès des
enfants du quartier
il est donné ici vient ici et bien cinq
minutes communauté est ce que tu sais ce
qui s'est passé là pourquoi est ce que
tu sais ce qui est arrivé ici il est
mort
annie pourquoi est ce qu'il est mort n'a
pas d'eau doit ils l'ont tué c'est qu'il
sait capter c'est la dette de sang oui
la dette de sang est ce que c'est bien
la vendetta non non bien sûr viens on va
faire une prière pour lui la dette de
sang c'est une très mauvaise chose on va
prier maintenant
à l'épreuve
as-tu notre père qui êtes aux cieux
70-66 fier que ton règne vienne que ta
volonté soit faite sur la terre comme au
ciel ci donne nous aujourd'hui notre
pain de ce jour
quand vous passerez par ici chaque fois
fait une prière pour que dieu fasse
qu'il n'y ait plus de vengeance se
venger ce n'est bon pour personne il ne
faut pas prendre le sens commun hasseni
est d'accord à quand un super pas chacun
un shop mois et après quand tu passera
par ici elle même vie demande à dieu qui
l'a cosef en soit la pyrénéenne chêne
pointu le fera à michael poole
aujourd'hui sur christina rendez-vous
celle où les lames r2f le jour même de
la mort de son fils elle a refusé la
vengeance et à pardonner
aux hôtes à de beaux raisins
jean messer bout elle a bien poussé
tavini donc à tenir un appel général on
aura de beaux raisins cette année on me
ramenait en colorant
c'était un chien c'est pourquoi fais tu
l'atmosphère est tendue la famille vient
d'apprendre qu'elle a sans doute basculé
dans un nouveau cycle de vengeance
l'oncle a la gâchette facile aurait à
nouveau frappé de la prison où il purge
sa peine il a prévenu lula doit cacher
ses fils maintenant ils l'ont transféré
dans un quartier de haute sécurité
pourquoi c'est ça que je veux savoir
pourquoi ils l'ont mis en haute sécurité
il faut qu'on sache je n'ai pas bien
compris au téléphone je vais demander
mais qu'est ce que tu as fait il a dit
je ne peux pas te raconter un bon
c'est sûr il ya quelque chose mais je ne
sais pas quoi
s'est passé quelque chose avec lui il
faut que j'aille le voir en prison
lou les appelle son deuxième fils mâle h
il ne doit plus rester dehors elle sent
qu'il est menacé l'oncle n'a pas donné
de détails de sa prison mais ici tout le
monde pense à un crime qu'ils appellent
une nouvelle vengeance
soeur christine apprend la sphère aux
mains
mais je contrat mais je connais
quelqu'un un policier en qui j'ai
confiance qui peut laisser traîner ses
oreilles afin de savoir ce qui s'est
passé au juste en prison
sans donner votre nom ni rien
ne vous inquiétez pas
c'est très important pan pan pan
on ya moi aussi je suis folle
d'inquiétude pour m'arracher
loulé va nous chercher les photos de
l'enterrement de son premier fils seif
est la peur maintenant pour moi lâche
on le voit ici m'a embrassé son frère
dans son cercueil
mais ce qui la mine c'est le petit
dernier il refuse de pardonner il veut
toujours venger son grand frère
maman m'a qu'il guide quand je lui ai
expliqué ce qui s'était passé quand je
vais grandir
je vais prendre le couteau et je vais
planter ce fils de chien comme ça
je ne l'avais jamais entendu parler
comme ça mais qu'est ce que tu dis là
mon fils je priais je demanderai
l'assassin de zf est venu les mains levé
avec du monde à notre porte comme le
veut la tradition et a demandé notre
pardon et nous lui avons donné dieu nous
a donné la force de pardonner il me
demande toujours pourquoi pourquoi on a
tué f qui a tué f j'ai fait une erreur
en lui disant la vérité
ne parle plus jamais comme ça mon fils
je lui ai dit c'est le christ qui a
pardonné la mort de m il me l'a promis
il m'a promis de ne plus jamais dire ça
mais je ne sais pas ce qu'il fera je ne
sais pas quoi faire que tu as bien fait
une jolie manolete ce que j'ai vécu je
ne le souhaite à personne
c'est ça qu'on appelle toutes les mères
à arrêter la dette de sang
il faut éloigner la haine
il faut dire non à la dette de son ça ne
nous apporte rien
ça nous enlève quelque chose car avec la
vengeance on n'a rien à gagner seulement
de la douleur et j'appelle tous les
pères à éduquer leurs enfants loin de la
vengeance et des assassinats
[Musique]
sur christina poursuit sa mission si
elle ne fait pas de miracle elle essaye
d'en provoquer
aujourd'hui elle cherche à obtenir le
pardon des tueurs qui veulent se venger
d'état
mais un salut
comment tu vas te dérange pas ça va
merci nous recevons
le petit garçon de d'état a été tué il y
a 6 ans au cours d'un différend au bord
d'un canal une sombre dispute de
poissons entre adolescents un accident
qui réclament vengeance son père doit le
venger mais la soeur a senti ses doutes
des questions au fils te manque beaucoup
il est au ciel et c'est là que tu va le
rejoindre et pour cela il faut que tu te
réconcilient j'en suis convaincue de
nuit la liberté
il se sentira libre enfin au ciel si tu
accordes le pardon tu penses à cela même
dans l'époque romane j'y songe toute
personne sensée doit-il songer
je sais que beaucoup exerce de la
pression sur toi te dise pourquoi te
venge tue pas as tu peur et tu as lâche
moi je sais que tu n'as pas peur
si tu accordes le pardon tu auras
réellement acquis loueur
mois laisse parler les gens laissent
courir les opinions des autres suis ce
que ton propre coeur et jésus de 10,1
cages sont très importants même si tous
ces gens disent qu'elles lâchent il n'a
pas mangé son fils jack ils le disent
n'est ce pas manqué à sa douce c'est
vrai il ya là beaucoup qu'ils disent oui
et c'est d'état
suit un homme sans jouer ça en toi tu
n'es pas seulement un homme d'honneur
parle toujours pour mon bien mais je ne
peux pas prendre une décision sans
consulter les autres hommes de la
famille
vous savez la réconciliation c'est une
décision collective
[Musique]
les cimetières du pays sont remplies de
victimes de la vendetta en albanie selon
les croyances l'âme d'un homme assassiné
ne trouve pas de repos tant qu'on ne tue
pas son meurtrier
les albanais estime devoir agir selon
les valeurs du canon
l'honneur avant tout l'honneur avant la
vie
[Musique]